همم لم تعد هذه الابقار مدلله هنا
احوال المزرعه تبدلت كثيرا
كل بقره لها مكانه عندك مال لكن عبء
تربيتها بات اكبر من طاقته
60 وظل عندنا 20 بسبب غلاء الاعلاف على
الدولار
وما عم بتطلع المردود تبعه
الحليب الى الثلث ومع قله المعروض ورفع
الدعم الحكوميه عن الاعلاف العام الماضي
سجلت اسعار الحديد ارتفاعا غير مسبوق
وتضاعف الامر مع ازمه الحبوب العالميه
نتيجه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
ارتفاع وكل فات في تربيه الابقار وتراجع
انتاج الحليب شكل ازمه وصلت الى الصناعات
الغذائيه التي يدخل الحليب في مكوناتها
فحلقت اسعارها بشكل قياسي
رفع محمود اسعار منتجاته بعدما الطراء الي
دفع مبالغ كبيره لتامين الحليب الطازج
لمصنعه
بينما عوض اخرون نقصه كما قال باستخدام
مكملات غذائيه اخرى على حساب الجوده
غلا لحقنا كثير من خلال المواد التغليف
اللي هي بلاستيك ونايلون ومازوت ولتصنيع
وكل هذه المواد اللي احنا بنشتريها
بالدولار
يبقى المستهلك الحلقه الاضعف هنا فقد بات
الغذاء والمفضل للاولاد بعيدا المنال
لعائلات كثيره كما تقول سعاد التي تحاول
ايجاد البدائل لطفلتها كلنا مقابل نشوف
كذا نوع جبنه هلا ما عاد فينا نشوف انواع
لانه صار كل شيء غالي
عملنا يعني نغمات بطاطا مسلوقه شويه لبن
شويه
[تصفيق]
عميقه اذن تكبر كل يوم كره ثلج وتاخذ في
طريقها قطاعه اضافيه مختلفه اخطرها ما
يتعلق بالامن الغذائي
كاترين حنا الجزيره البقاع شرقيه لبنان